[Music]
Bernadette I know you're home
apparently I hope you don't mind I
called the BlackBerry abatement
specialist the blackberry vines are
coming under the wall it's in my raised
vegetable beds my worm bins it stomp
Bernadette Fox no car Bernadette Fox was
simply the most exciting thing in the
world of architecture 20 years ago
I think what happened in my mom is that
she got so focused on her family she
forgot about herself
honey are you getting enough sleep sleep
what's up yeah so from what you're
saying she ran over a mother at school
Bernadette's going what do we do what
men she created an environment which
destroyed a neighbor's home
[Music]
I just split into my home Japanese
maples the birdbath in my living room
people like you must create if you don't
you become a menace to society
[Music]
unexpected has come up just thinking
about it's got my heart rate burning she
disappeared Bernadette jumped out a
window there's one answer to all of your
problems get your ass back to work
a huge project has come up it will
require me to go to Antarctica it's
twice the challenge anyone ever imagines
with long stretches without sleep and
exercise sounds like I've been in
training for this for the last 20 years
I have this longshot to launch my second
act so step aside because I am about to
kick the hell out of life
world domination ain't pretty
[Music]